the Joe Rogan experience and honestly
particularly in the last 15 years when I
started really taking martial arts
seriously half the stuff that I've been
able to do right in my creative life are
principles that I learned on the mat
with my Sifu mmm you know guard your
center keep your eye on the lead elbow
get to the blindside
you know how often you do that was
started I think I'm in 15th or 16th year
Sifu is over
day before yesterday so you know a bunch
of times a week and if I'm working on
something or if he can make it the
location will have long stretches where
we're doing it every day and there's
gradings so you got a prep for those you
know mm-hmm it's so what are you doing
you're doing kung-fu like is it a very
particular style traditional Wing Chun
really yeah which is very underrated art
form yes also so many trade secrets and
so different than how I see it when I'm
looking at videos and that in UFC
everything is out in the open and it's
discussed and you see and a lot of the
eastern stuff there was a turf wars and
we're not really going to show them our
footwork we're not going to do this so
but anyway it's been a real deep dive
with my seafood Eric Oram whose seafood
my C gung as Grand Master William Cheung
renowned kind of Hong Kong rooftop
fights all that stuff amazing lore but
very technical difficult to build and
easy to use you know it's you very
rarely see that in the UFC but one of
the best fighters in the UFC uses it
regularly
Tony 20 Ferguson 20 Ferguson uses
trapping hands the Mook Jeong yeah yeah
he grabs wrists and comes over the top
with elbows he does straight wing chun
he does it all the time and even
practices on a wooden wooden dummy
I got my ass kicked by a wooden dummy
for about three years and then I finally
understood the principle of don't fight
force it force and you know it's just
nuts
so anyway half the time if I would be in
a critical artistic situation I would
just say because Wing Chun problems are
life problems life problems are Wing
Chun problems and I would just go back
to how did this kind of relate to
because I don't like getting clocked and
getting my teeth knocked in because we
tend to sometimes we glove up but we're
not wearing mouthpieces it's very it's
certainly not because he's very good at
pulling his punches and he's also even
better at making sure that I don't
accidentally hit him but we get as close
as we can to what the real experience
would be but again it's like everything
I'm sure you know a few clicks back down
the road there's things that instructors
were doing that would be considered
illegal to do to a group of students
nowadays yeah for sure
so not just a few clicks while I was
coming up that's what I would imagine
yeah students would get beat up normal
you so did you start training for
Sherlock Holmes or you start training
before I didn't it absolutely coincided
with my recovery and the two things just
somehow or other seem to to lock in when
and talk to you off the record and
afterwards about any and everything to
do with my recovery as far as it locked
into this it was an apprentice and
apprenticeship and it was an
apprenticeship that was contingent on me
being in a certain headspace mmm well
it's a good thing too because it's an
it's a very addictive thing people get
very addicted to martial arts and it's a
good substitute for sometimes negative
addictions
you know Bourdain before he died he was
obsessed with Brazilian Jujitsu yeah
became really obsessed with it at 58
when and got really good he was he was
training every day and he was trained
twice a day every day so he went from
when I first met him he was chubby he
was smoking cigarettes he drank every
night still kind of still drank every
night but you know he just did enough to
enough healthy things keep his body
together and then his ex-wife got really
into jiu-jitsu and then he decided to
follow her one day to classes and he was
kind of mocking it and laughing at it at
first and then became obsessed and then
really got good I mean he was and at the
look at I won in a tournament and I mean
oh my god yeah he's [ __ ] 60 years old
age what's really crazy is a picture of
him walking down the street and I think
they were in Rome and he has no shirt on
and he's [ __ ] ripped Anthony Bourdain
full six-pack yeah dude he was obsessed
he would take a private everyday look at
him look at that photo that's crazy he's
like 60 something years old there so he
would take a private lesson every day
and then he would take a class so we
take a private lesson sharpen up
techniques and they roll yeah take group
classes too which is very very critical
you gotta roll with different people
how do percentage and so he was in there
like and it became a good thing for him
to sort of become addicted to this
positive thing yeah I mean for me it
wasn't gonna be golf it was gonna be
something passive like that right oh I
hear it's great but it's been it's just
been a great gift and it's also that
thing where you know you're just you're
never done I'm a black belt five years
ago for another grading and now we're
doing a lot of weapons stuff and it's
just awesome resolutions yeah my tag
window teacher said something to me when
I was very young they said that it is a
tool for developing your human potential
yeah and I never forgot that because I'm
like yeah it's because it's really
difficult to do like all martial arts or
really it's really difficult to get your
body to move that way and to be able to
be effective in a conflict situation and
if you can do it you can do it over and
over again and you can overcome that
difficult thing and you thought it was
insurmountable and then you figured out
how to do it eventually you get to this
point you realized well everything in
life
is like that everything in life is like
something that's a puzzle you have to
figure out what how am i approaching it
wrong what can I do to make it better
how do I get more competent at this
particular skill or this particular
discipline yeah and just the humility to
I mean if I've noticed anything in the
last couple of years Justin in UFC which
by the way I was doing a Robert Altman
film called the gingerbread man back in
the 90s and I UFC it just start off and
I was getting the VHS tapes yeah and
watching them and so when they go back
on the 25 years ago I was like I've been
I've been I've been there from jump
that's awesome but we watch it's just
that thing of no matter what you think
the the tides are changing quickly and
yeah and you just got to keep keep
working well that was a real wake-up
call for a lot of martial artists was
the UFC there's a lot of the stuff that
they were doing really wasn't effective
yeah they thought it would be if
everybody was playing by the rules in
the dojo and sort of following along
though but once you really saw actual
cage event where people were just going
balls out you realize a lot of this
stuff just doesn't work yeah I'd love
how messy it was at the beginning
because the style matchups were so if
they were almost crazy laughable until
you until you saw the violence and no
weight classes
[Applause]